in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Mike
and Heather are with us hey guys how are
you we deserve I love it good to have
you were you guys from Minneapolis
Minnesota very cool
welcome and you're here to do your
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off
sixty-five thousand eight hundred three
dollars and 21 cents I love it very cool
and how long did that take you six years
six years six years and 13 days making
what kind of money during that time um
starting at just over 29,000 and
currently at 65,000 doubled your income
during that time more than doubled it
mm-hmm yep very well done so what kind
of debt was the 66,000 majority of it
was student loans
there was about 3,500 we owned and
personal debt and the rest of it was
straight student loans yeah okay so six
years is a long time y'all yeah man
you've been scratching and clawing for a
while so uh what's the story how did
this all happen well it's kind of funny
actually this started for me in 2007
friend of mine told me about you and at
the time I said you know if there's dirt
on Dave I'll find it I don't have to
worry about it I started researching on
what you taught and I had actually paid
off my first credit card before I
started the class the following spring
uh yeah and then I met Heather shortly
after that and yeah her parents said we
had to take your class to get engaged
and so we did that oh there we go
we finished April 2009 and we got
engaged end of May of 2009 and then got
married in October 2009 very cool good
and so you begin to hold that snowball
thing living on a budget the whole
process but you weren't making a ton of
money so when did the income go up about
a year and a half ago okay so most of
the six years you've been doing this on
a like a thirty thousand dollar income
yeah yeah I'm beginning raises every
year but you know we had a big jump left
last summer okay we paid off my student
loans in the last 12 months okay boom
just like that so kind of on the end
here there was a like a blow-up a
breakthrough yeah very cool
that's pretty incredible that you stuck
with something six years most people
can't stay with stuff six minutes so
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is stay focused yeah
stay focused and when you screw up just
keep going yeah because you know six
years is a long time we had him in the
time of that and I got married we had
cars explode yep you know you just have
to keep going when things bad things
happen yeah just keep plowing through
get back up do it again get back up do
it again right Wow well congratulations
you too
what do you tell people the key gig out
of debt is that's poking us then stick
to it that's the whole thing it's pretty
much it and don't be afraid to screw up
you know you just screw up you just keep
going and you try again okay because
here we are today [ __ ] I don't hear debt
free that's right how's it feel
after six years or like you know what we
need to actually have a family vacation
and go see Dave Wow I'm honored I'm
honored you picked this as a stop very
cool
all right Mike and Heather from
Minneapolis $66,000 paid off in six
years making twenty nine now all the way
up to 65 here lately count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
very well done